hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
features of Plato's symposium that can
often be confusing for a first or second
or third or many time readers occurs
early on and runs throughout the entire
text and it's what we could call the
narrative framework this is in effect a
story within a story within a story that
also includes some other stories nested
inside them sort of like peeling an
onion or those Russian dolls and most of
the the framing is going to occur in the
early part a little we're going to see
this story told by Socrates about the
oedema coming in towards the end so what
I want to do in this video is just give
an overview of the framing and how these
different narratives which we're all
really the same narrative are nested
inside of each other so that you can see
exactly what's going on and then we'll
think a little bit about why Plato might
be doing this although it's you know
there nobody can really say for certain
precisely why he does that before we go
into that I do want to say that this is
not a feature that's unique to the
symposium but its most complex in that
text there are other Platonic dialogues
and I think for example about the Phaedo
or about the theaetetus where
you know let me tell you a story about
the conversations that happened sort of
structure is there in place as well now
you notice that I've got narrator one
and that narrator two these are two
different characters and we're going to
see how they're connected together in a
moment and then I've got this sort of
you know large frame here Agathon's
party that narrator - is a part of and
then we have this this deeper level do
Donna and the young Socrates not the
Socrates who is present as an old man
while he is really the same Socrates
right because he's telling the story but
he's not at the same age so we also have
some shifts in time that should be
signaled as well the main action of the
story is happening in this this you know
party room at Athens around 416 BC the
story is being told somewhere in between
say 402 to 399 BC so to say around 400
BC it's supposed to have been written
later on so Plato is addressing an
audience that would already have this as
a past this is a yet further past and
then this is a much more distant past so
we've got this guy Apollodorus and the
story begins with Apollodorus having a
conversation with a friend very quickly
we're going to get another frame of
reference coming in with these allusions
to another friend of his Glaucon so the
front man Apollodorus that's the most
outer core or or husk of this dialogue
and that's where we're hearing the story
we could think of ourselves as being as
readers in the place of this friend
asking Apollodorus hey can you tell me
about the time that these speeches were
going on I'd kind of like to know about
that so
Apollodorus says to his friend well it's
fortunate that you're asking me about
this now because just a few days ago the
time between these conversation
is just a few days I was talking with
glauca and Glaucon asked me exactly the
same thing that you were inquiring about
now and I told him the story then so
I've still got it fresh in my mind I'm
gonna tell you the whole thing but
Glaucon is confused
Glaucon is a bit mixed up because he
thinks that all of this happened just a
little while ago it didn't happen around
400 BC it happened in 416 BC but but
Blanca thinks that this is all over here
that's in part cuz he got it from
another guy Phoenix who is an
intermediary between the story and the
eyewitness who is who's telling the
story to Apollodorus Arista Dimas so
this guy Phoenix we don't really know
much about him he's just sort of a bit
player in this and Phoenix didn't quite
get it right he garbled things up and so
Blanca now has a mistaken counsel
Apollodorus is going to set him straight
by telling the story as it happened as
he got it from the person who was there
so you know already we can say well are
we getting exactly what would took place
this is not meant to be a historical
account Plato is is engaging in some
some literary devices here by having the
story being told by somebody else and
then related by somebody else to us it's
supposed to create a kind of distance
you could think of this as the once upon
a time trope that we use for telling
fairy tales so let's move now from
Apollodorus to this guy or mr. Dimas
arista Dimas is there present as an
eyewitness and even as a participant to
some degree in the very first parts of
this this party account for the the
whole sequence of speeches that are
going to take place there is one moment
where he dozes off or when we might say
passes out he wakes up at the end of the
party
everybody else is passed out except for
Socrates Aristophanes and Agathon the
heavy weights the tragic poet the
comedic poet and Socrates is the
representative of philosophy who have
managed to stay up all night long and
are still hashing out an argument which
we don't see any resolution to about the
possibility of the same person being
both a comic and a tragic poet by the
way some people think that that that's a
way of Plato bringing himself into the
narrative because one of the things that
Plato is able to do is to incorporate
tragedy comedy and all these other
genres into his own genre the platonic
dialogue in any case arista Dimas is now
telling the story to Apollodorus so
Apollodorus has it from the wrists Dimas
Apollodorus says I also want you know
talked with Socrates to make sure that I
was getting the true story we don't know
exactly what he asked him but he has
sort of the imprimatur of Socrates yeah
you've got it mostly right but as far as
I can tell go ahead and now you you can
tell the story as he's going to do with
us Arisa Dimas it is going to be there
he's not invited to Agathon's party at
least he didn't get the invitation
Agathon after where it says oh I wanted
you to come but you know we weren't able
to get a hold of you but he runs into
socrates and socrates is on the way to a
science party why do we know that it's
416 BC at least in the narrative
framework because this is Agathon's
first victory party after his first
success in the festival of Dimas so
swear the tragedies would be put on
judged and then prizes would be awarded
he's won so we know and that is supposed
to have taken place this time is also
important because of some of the other
characters for two other historical
events that any audience member you know
or any reader getting this text in
Plato's time would be very conversant
with and that's the the Syracuse and
exhibition where
where Athens sort of rolled the dice and
came up short and the disfiguring of
these religious statues the disfiguring
of the Hermits that famous and who else
Phaedrus and I think Eric's amigas were
thought to have participated in now all
of this is important because this is
where in the narrative once we've sort
of penetrated into the past by Plato
saying let me tell you a story now I got
this story from this guy and he was
there once we've done that we're here in
this narrative past this is the third
level of the dialogue and what's going
to happen is a whole sequence of
speeches there's a lot of interesting
stuff going on and I'm not going to go
into any detail about that in this video
because I'm doing plenty of other core
concept videos about that but I do want
to signal what is happening as far as
narrative time and this this structure
of you know unfolding and narrative
within a narrative with a few of these
speeches
Aristophanes he is going to tell a way
back story which he's pretty much you
know making up as he goes along
this is plato's coming up with a
Aristophanes sort of myth a comedic tale
being told about you know human beings
way back in the early days being these
creatures that had two heads two you
know two heads two sets of genitals four
arms four legs getting split down the
middle by the gods and all the things
that happened after that so you could
send through the story within a story
there alcibiades is also going to tell a
story and I haven't put the kind of
framing here in part because the person
who's telling the story about happens to
be there and in Socrates Socrates is
going to tell a story about himself and
eodum I also buy these is going to tell
a story about himself and Socrates a
story that in a certain way is like a
confessional tell he's he's admitting to
having done something rather
trying to seduce Socrates trying to get
Socrates to be sexually interested in in
him it doesn't work and that's part of
why he says Socrates is such a great guy
so Alcibiades is also telling a story
within a story but it's not at the level
of the do demo portion when Socrates
comes up to give his speech he's not
gonna play by the rules because
oftentimes Socrates doesn't he's not
going to just give a long discourse the
way everybody else does he questions
anethe on about you know Agathon's on
speech shows Agathon doesn't know what
he's talking about kind of typical
Socrates not a great dinner guest if you
if you want somebody who's gonna just
you know how have everybody get along
and not bring up any controversial
topics but then what Socrates does is he
says I can't really give a speech but I
can tell you about this encounter that I
had when I was a young man so now what
are we doing we're moving down to get a
further deeper layer of the narrative
these are all historical persons these
arguably are as well we're not sure
about Dilma the Odom amay may not have
existed she may have been a literary
creation of Plato she may have been
somebody who actually did exist and her
name was the oedema and did teach
Socrates she may be signaling some other
person there's there's various theories
about this but in any case Socrates is
now transporting us out of 416 BC and
we're way past 400 BC into his youth
essentially his his adolescence when he
was himself learning about love from
this older wise woman who you know
supposed to have done all sorts of
interesting things and she tells him or
rather she in part tells him and also
engages in dialectical questioning and
answering she engages in Socratic
dialogue with him about the nature of
love where we're actually going to lead
with Socrates own contribution is down
at this level and then it's the bursting
in by Alcibiades that takes us out of
this level and back into the room
Alcibiades shows up it's sort of add a
new mom to the PCs that use drunk
everybody else hasn't been drinking very
hard but Elsa by DS is drunk he's were
there with a bunch of other drunks and
then he tells his story and then the
whole party breaks down now we start to
move back out into the narrative as we
have it here it leaves off not getting
us up to this level but with the risk
Dimas finishing up the story by saying
well you know after I came to I found
these three guys still locked in
conversation Socrates then got back up
and walked out and continued on with
with his day Socrates had this you know
Constitution I don't drink as much as
that you want it without being affected
so that is the narrative framework as
you're approaching this text this is
something worth keeping in mind now do
we know why Plato I actually did this
there's there's a lot of theories
perhaps he's doing something to make it
deliberately just a literary creation
not making any assertions about this
being a historical event perhaps what
he's suggesting other other commentators
have said is that we can't really know
what's going on in the symposium perhaps
some of these are what we call narrators
who are not giving us the entire story
we know that some of things have been
left out Larisa Dimas says that he
doesn't remember all of the speeches
these are the speeches that he remembers
do we really have enough to go on to say
that any of these are unreliable
narrators we don't even have enough for
that so really all we're left with in
the end is this framework which remains
an open question for us